>>> NEW REPORTING THIS MORNING,
CNN HAS LEARNED THAT THE U.S. IS
DEVELOPING CONTINGENCY PLANS FOR
POSSIBLE RUSSIAN ESCALATION IN
ITS WAR IN UKRAINE, INCLUDING
THE POTENTIAL USE OF TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
ALSO THE POSSIBILITY OF WHAT ONE
SOURCE DESCRIBED AS A NUCLEAR
DISPLAY, THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
SHORT OF A NUCLEAR STRIKE,
INCLUDING THE POSSIBILITY OF A
MILITARY STRIKE ON THE
ZAPORIZHZHIA NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT.
JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS,
RETIRED BRIGADIER GENERAL MARK
KENNEDY, ALSO FORMER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR PLANS AND STRATEGY
AT U.S. NCOM.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON THIS
MORNING.
>> HI, JIM, HOW ARE YOU?
>> SO THIS SHOWS HOW SERIOUSLY
THE U.S. IS TAKING THESE RUSSIAN
NUCLEAR THREATS.
THEY'VE BEEN DEVELOPING
CONTINGENCY PLANS FOR SOME TIME.
I WONDER CAN YOU DESCRIBE WHAT
SUCH CONTINGENCY PLANS MIGHT
INVOLVE?
>> WELL, I THINK, FIRST OF ALL,
THERE IS THE PUBLIC FACE OF ALL
OF THIS, WHICH IS HOW WE
COMMUNICATE TO RUSSIA WHAT WE'RE
PREPARED TO DO AND WHAT WE ARE
NOT PREPARED TO DO.
MY PERSONAL VIEW IS I THINK WE
OUGHT TO BE DELIBERATELY VAGUE
ON WHAT WE ARE PREPARED TO DO.
ANYTIME YOU DRAW A RED LINE,
THAT COMMITS YOU TO A CERTAIN
COURSE OF ACTION.
LOOK, I THINK IT'S FAIRLY SIMPLE
TO LAY DOWN THE OPTIONS, IT
COULD BE THE SOFT SIDE OF IT,
WHICH IS DOUBLING DOWN ON
SANCTIONS, DOUBLING DOWN ON
EXPORT CONTROLS, RANGING ALL THE
WAY TO A NUCLEAR RESPONSE OF OUR
OWN AND EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
>> WOW.
>> WOULD BE LIKELY THAT THIS
PRESIDENT IS NOT LOOKING AT THE
FAR END OF THAT, SORT OF OF
LOOKING AT A RESPONSE IN KIND,
BUT NOT WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
HARD STRIKES ON RUSSIAN
FACILITIES INSIDE OF UKRAINE
MOST LIKELY.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY HOW GENERAL
PETRAEUS DESCRIBED IT, HE SAID
HYPOTHETICALLY AND, AGAIN, HE IS
NOT BASING THIS ON ANY PUBLIC
REVELATION OF INTELLIGENCE, WE
WOULD RESPOND BY LEADING A NATO
COLLECTIVE EFFORT THAT WOULD
TAKE OUT EVERY RUSSIAN
CONVENTIONAL FORCE THAT WE COULD
SEE AND IDENTIFY ON THE
BATTLEFIELD IN UKRAINE, ALSO IN
CRIMEA.
DOES THAT SOUND LIKE THE
RESPONSE YOU WOULD BE THINKING
OF?
>> WELL, I CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE
A VOTE IN THE MATTER BUT I THINK
THAT'S CERTAINLY ONE OF THE
OPTIONS THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED.
I'M GLAD TO SEE I'M IN GOOD
COMPANY AS GENERAL PETRAEUS.
>> THE CONCERN FROM THE START OF
THIS WAR WHICH HAS QUALIFIED
REALLY EVERY U.S. NATO STEP IN
RESPONSE TO THE RUSSIAN
INVASION, THE QUALITY OF
WEAPONS, THE RANGE OF WEAPONS,
THE DEGREE OF MILITARY SUPPORT
FOR UKRAINE HAS BEEN CONCERNS
ABOUT SPARKING A BROADER WAR
WITH RUSSIA, FOR INSTANCE,
THAT'S WHY THE IDEA OF A NO FLY
ZONE AS ELIMINATED BECAUSE THAT
WOULD BE PUTTING NATO WAR PLANES
IN DIRECT CONFLICT WITH RUSSIAN
FORCES.
WOULD A RESPONSE LIKE THIS, AND
THIS HAS TO BE PART OF THE
CALCULATION, RIGHT, THERE IS A
RISK OF SPARKING A BROADER WAR,
IS THERE NOT?
>> THERE CERTAINLY IS, BUT I
HEARD A DESCRIPTION OF PUTIN
YESTERDAY THAT I THOUGHT WAS
PARTICULARLY APT.
HE STARTED OFF AS AN AUTOCRAT,
BECAME A DICTATOR AND NOW HE IS
A MADMAN.
>> WOW.
>> HE MAY BE A MADMAN, BUT I
DON'T THINK HE'S SUICIDAL.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT HE WANTS TO
BE THE LEADER OF RUSSIA THAT
ENDS THE RUSSIAN FEDERATION.
SO I THINK WE OUGHT TO TAKE HIS
THREATS SERIOUSLY, BUT I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD BE COWED OR
COERCE DS IN ANY PARTICULAR
ACTION AS A RESULT.
>> THE U.S. TO DATE HAS NOT
DETECTED ANY MOVEMENTS OF
RUSSIAN NUCLEAR FORCES OR
WEAPONS THAT WOULD INDICATE THE
ATTACK IS IMMINENT.
I DO WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
BATTLEFIELD AND UKRAINIAN
PROGRESS.
WE SAW THAT RAPID ADVANCE IN THE
NORTHEAST AT THE START OF THIS
COUNTEROFFENSIVE, NOW WE'RE
SEEING IF NOT QUITE RAPID
ADVANCE BUT STILL SUBSTANTIAL
ADVANCE IN THE SOUTH AROUND
KHERSON.
HOW BAD IS THE SITUATION FOR
RUSSIA AND IT'S FORCES?
HAVE WE SEEN THE BEGINNING OF A
BROADER RETREAT HERE?
>> THAT'S HARD TO SAY, JIM,
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT IT FROM
CLASSIC MILITARY ANALYSIS, THE
RUSSIANS SHOULD BE DOING FAR,
FAR BETTER, A QUANTITATIVE
ASSESSMENT BECAUSE THAT THE
RUSSIANS HAVE THE ADVANTAGE, BUT
IT'S THE INTANGIBLES THAT WE'RE
SEEING ON THE BATTLEFIELD.
THE MORALE OF THE UKRAINIANS,
THE EQUIPMENT THEY HAVE, THE
LEADERSHIP THAT THEY HAVE,
VERSUS THE EXACT OPPOSITE ON THE
SIDE OF THE RUSSIANS.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN TAKE A
CONVENTIONAL MILITARY RULER AND
MEASURE THIS AS WELL AS MAY HAVE
BEEN IN THE PAST.
I DON'T PARTICULARLY THINK
THERE'S GOING TO BE A BREAK OUT
ANYTIME SOON BUT THERE WILL BE
CONTINUED PRESSURES ON THE
RUSSIANS BOTH IN THE NORTH AND
THE SOUTH.
>> BRIGADIER GENERAL MARK
KIMMETT, GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON
THIS MORNING.
THANKS SO MUCH.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING
THIS, A RANGE OF OFFICIALS
SUGGESTED THAT IF RUSSIA
DETONATED A NUCLEAR WEAPON ON
UKRAINIAN SOIL, THE OPTIONS ARE
UNPLUGGING RUSSIA FROM THE WORLD
ECONOMY OR A MILITARY RESPONSE.
JOINING US NOW ONE OF THE
REPORTERS BEHIND THE STORY, CNN
POLITICAL AND NATIONAL SECURITY
ANALYST DAVID SINGER.
THIS IS SUCH A GREAT STORY I
THINK BECAUSE IT PUTS US IN THE
MOMENT WE'RE IN, WHICH IS KIND
OF AN ALARMING ONE, ALTHOUGH YOU
DO POINT OUT, FOR INSTANCE,
THERE ARE SOME REASONS WHY
SENIOR OFFICIALS ARE SAYING NOT
TO BE FULLY CONCERNED AT THIS
POINT IN TIME.
BUT PUT IN CONTEXT WHERE WE ARE.
>> I THINK WHERE WE ARE, THIS IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST FRAUGHT
NUCLEAR MOMENTS SINCE THE CUBAN
MISSILE CRISIS WHICH WAS 60
YEARS AGO THIS MONTH.
THAT SAID, THERE'S NO EVIDENCE
RIGHT NOW THAT WE SEE THE
RUSSIANS MOVING ANY TACTICAL
WEAPONS.
THEY'RE SMALL SO IT MIGHT BE
EASY TO MISS THEM, BUT THERE'S
NO EVIDENCE OF THAT AT THIS
POINT.
AND THEY DON'T BELIEVE THAT
PUTIN YET HAS HIS BACK SO UP
AGAINST THE WALL THAT HE WOULD
TURN TO THIS.
IT'S ALSO NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR HOW
MUCH USING A TACTICAL WEAPON
WOULD HELP HIM ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
EXCEPT TO TRY TO FREEZE THINGS.
TO SAY TO THE UKRAINIANS IF YOU
MAKE ONE MORE MOVE TOWARD
THROWING US OUT OF THE DONBAS OR
THESE OTHER AREAS, JUST KNOW
THAT I CAN TAKE OUT YOUR ENTIRE
COUNTRY AND TURN IT ALL INTO
WASTE LAND.
BUT THE CONSEQUENCES FOR PUTIN
WOULD BE HIGH.
>> SURELY PUTIN KNOWS AMONG
THOSE CONVENTIONS WOULD BE
GLOBAL CONDEMNATION.
THERE ARE STILL SOME COUNTRIES
THAT HE HAS SOMEWHAT ON HIS
SIDE, INCLUDING CHINA.
HE MUST KNOW THAT HE WOULD VERY
QUICKLY LOSE THAT SUPPORT IF HE
WERE TO DO ANYTHING ON THE
NUCLEAR FRONT.
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
I DON'T THINK HE WOULD.
AND CHINA AND INDIA ARE TWO
COUNTRIES THAT ARE CONTINUING TO
BUY OIL, FOR EXAMPLE, AND NOT
PART OF THE MAJOR SANCTIONS
REGIME.
AT THE SAME TIME WHAT WORRIES
MOST AMERICAN OFFICIALS IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN PUTIN COMES TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT THE WAR IS GOING
SO BADLY IT'S A THREAT TO NOT
ONLY RUSSIA BUT TO HIM.
AND AT THAT MOMENT HE MAY REACH
FOR WHATEVER HE'S GOT.
HE MAY ALSO THINK THAT OVER TIME
OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE BROKEN
TABOOS AND GOTTEN AWAY WITH IT.
NOTICE IN THE SPEECH THE FIRST
THING -- THE ONE LAST WEEK, THE
FIRST THING HE SAID THERE WAS
HIROSHIMA, NAGASAKI AND YOU SET
A PRECEDENCE WHEN YOU DID THAT.
>> THAT'S PART OF HIS CAMPAIGN
OF RATIONALIZATION.
SAYING THEY SET THE PRECEDENT.
THE U.S. SET THE PRECEDENT.
HE'S ALSO ON THE RATIONALIZATION
HAD THESE ILLEGAL ANNEXATIONS OF
THESE FOUR AREAS OF UKRAINE.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT RUSSIAN
MILITARY DOCTRINE.
AND HE KEEPS RE-EMPHASIZING THIS
AS HAVE OTHER OFFICIALS, NUCLEAR
WEAPONS CAN BE USED IF THERE IS
AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO RUSSIA
NOW IT SEEMS THE RATIONALIZATION
IS THIS IS RUSSIA, IF YOU GO
AFTER THIS, WE CAN USE A NUKE.
>> THAT IS THE BACKWARDS
RATIONA
RATIONALIZATION.
IT WOULD ALSO SEEM TO APPLY TO
CRIMEA, WE'VE SEEN THE
UKRAINIANS ATTACK CRIMEA AND
HE'S NOT REACHED FOR NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
THE ODDITY IS NUCLEAR WEAPONS
ARE ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT ARE
MUCH MORE POWERFUL IN THE
PERSPECTIVE.
IN THE THREAT THAT YOU MIGHT USE
IT.
THAN THEY ARE WHEN YOU ACTUALLY
GO OFF TO USE IT.
THIS IS NOT LIKE THE OLD COLD
WAR DAYS WHERE THE CONCERN WAS
THEY WOULD LOB A NUCLEAR WEAPON
AT THE UNITED STATES, IN RETURN
FOR NEW YORK YOU TAKE OUT MOSCOW
OR WHATEVER.
IN THIS CASE HE'S TALKING ABOUT
USING A SMALL WEAPON THAT WOULD
BE USED ON PRESUMABLY A MILITARY
BASE, MAYBE A LOW POPULATED
AREA.
THE WEST IS NOT GOING TO FIRE A
NUCLEAR WEAPON BACK IN RETURN
FOR THAT.
THEY MAY ACTUALLY, AS WE
REPORTED, USE CONVENTIONAL
WEAPONS.
THERE COULD BE SOME KIND OF
MILITARY RESPONSE BUT NOT A
NUCLEAR RESPONSE.
SO HE MAY WELL THINK THAT, YOU
KNOW, OVER TIME HE WOULD GET
AWAY WITH THIS.
HE THINKS OVER TIME THE WEST IS
GOING TO LOSE INTEREST IN
UKRAINE.
AS THE WINTER SETS IN EUROPE,
THE INTEREST IN CONTINUING THE
SANCTIONS IS GOING TO DIMINISH.
WE'VE SEEN PROTESTS IN EUROPE
ABOUT HIGH PRICES AND SHORTAGES.
HE'S BETTING WE'LL LOSE